[موسيقى]
حركه طالبان حكومه دون اعتراف دولي ولا
داخلي الا ان الحركه تمارس قمع الانسانيا
وسياسيا ومهنيا
قوانين مقيده فرضتها طالبان على المواطنين
الافغان الذين قبلوا بها مجبرين لا مخيرين
ماذا فعل الامم المتحده للتحذير من كارثه
انسانيه لانهيار سياده النظام القانونيه
فبعد سيطرتها على افغانستان علق طالبان
دستور عام 2004 وعزلت جميع القضاه من هيئه
المحكمه وجردت مكتب المدعي العام من دوره
الرئيسيه بات القسم الذي ادلى به المحامون
والقضاء حبل مشنقه تعلقه طالبان على رقاب
المعرضين منهم لاحكامها كما تم اقصاء
النساء وتجريدهن من حقوقهن الاساسيات سواء
التعليمه او العمل او غيرهما
من قبل الحركه التي لم تستثني النظام
القانوني
عامل وصفته الامم المتحده بالعمل التمييزي
الواضح حيث فصل الطالبان اكثر من 200 250
قاضيه ومئات من المحميات والمدعين العامين
في حين هرب العديد من القضيه من البلاد او
اختبائن باتت افغانستان تحت نظام من غير
مستقله ونظام حركه تستخدم سلاح ضد من كل
فوق بتطبيق العدل اكثر من 10 مدعينين
معظمهم من الرجال قتلوا على ايدي مجهولنا
ويقال ان العديد منهم ما زالوا مختبئين
الامم المتحده قالت بان ما يتعرض له
العاملون في جهات انفاذ القانون في مقصره
طالبان يتطلب تحركا فوريا من قبل المجتمع
الدوليه لوقفه تلك الممارسات التعسفيه
روان حمزه العربيه